hey a quick note before this one begins
Resident Evil 4 is quite a dark game if
you're watching on mobile or tablet I
recommend boosting your brightness all
good okay let's do this hello there from
nods to the speedrunning community to
iconic callbacks to the original game
here are 30 Resident Evil 4 remake
Secrets Easter eggs and amazing details
a Resident Evil game isn't official
without a Jill Valentine Easter egg and
in the remake it's Ashley who gets the
honor after boosting her up to a wall
for the umpteenth time she'll kindly
unlock the door and remark
pretty much a master of Milwaukee
ogre fans will know this from the very
first time we ever played Resident Evil
back in the PS1 days I forgot how little
pixels there was back then that's better
Joe here's a lock pick
it might be handy if you the master of
unlocking take it with you
pretty much a master of Milwaukee
the first major encounter in Resident
Evil 4 is set in this Village and Leon
must survive until a bell tower Rings
stopping his attackers
well people cleverer than I found out we
can shoot that Bell and skip the entire
fight it's a tough shot to make but it
is possible and think of all the ammo
you'll save and as the villagers walk
away Leon reminds us about his Dreadful
comedy one-liners
where's everyone going
bingo
Bingo actually gets another reference in
the final recap of your playthrough
honeygun's computer gives us our results
and take a look at the Post-it note at
the bottom she's planning to go to bingo
with all her friends and family so I
guess everyone is going to Bingo where's
everyone going bingo the merchant is a
total Legend in re4 with tons of voice
lines you're in for a treat stick around
long enough and he'll start humming the
save room theme from the original game
[Music]
this lovable stranger also has a
shooting gallery to take part in and
another musical quiz does this sound
familiar to you
and that's the game it turns out that's
the song that was on the radio back in
2005 at the very opening of the game I
received special training via a secret
organization working under the direct
control of the president
and that's the game impressive detail
down here we can complete shooting
drills to be awarded tokens which are
then turned into charms which slightly
change our game one of those is this the
striker shotgun which gives us Plus 8
running speed this turns out to be a
shout out to the ditman glitch a
speedrunning community favorite from
back in 2007. it's the Holy Grail of
speedrunning a trick that makes
everything faster ditman discovered that
by glitching that shotgun your character
would move quicker therefore
speedrunners love this and shattered so
many world records re4 remake is packed
with updated versions of Easter eggs
from the original 2005 game for example
back on the PS2 we could find one of the
infected urinating in a loo in the
village Chief's house and in the update
he's there once again but this time he's
doing a number two if you're quick
enough and get around the corner you can
see him if you wanted to I don't know
why you would and by the look of things
Las plagas plays havoc with your
digestive system and I've lowered the
tone already so let's keep that going
the smutty comments and glimpses of
Ashley's undergarments were removed in
the remake remember this line I see that
the president's equipped his daughter
with Ballistics too how rude back then
boob physics were cutting edge
technology and games regularly brought
attention to them especially Japanese
ones for some reason but where in 2023
we are above this right well no once
you've completed the game it's possible
to purchase models in the gallery and
guess who gets boob physics none other
than Ashley and Ada I know nobody asked
and I look quite sus right now but look
at this Ada's model has a badonkadunk
jiggle physics too before I can get
canceled again back to more Easter eggs
Ashley will hit this pose in the game if
she ever visits the gun range which is
almost identical from the renders of the
game back in the 2000s a surprising
callback back to an unreleased version
of Resident Evil 4 dubbed 3.5 can be
seen when playing as Ashley
out of all the things to give us a jump
scare it had to be a deer's head hung on
the wall well that asset was lovingly
recreated and updated from this re
trailer it was so early the game didn't
even have a release year back then 2000
dandex the names of a few trophies and
achievements in re4 remake are once
again made for players of the old school
game for example by defeating Mendes in
this Burning Barn we receive this trophy
grilled Big Cheese Big Cheese was the
name Lewis gave this Village Chief in
the original game The Big Cheese what
another one of Salazar's minions can be
defeated in the sewers the Verdugo when
you finally fell him the trophy waved
goodbye right hand appears this is
thanks to yet another weird Leon
conversation from 2005 between him and
Salazar
[Music]
sent my right hand to dispose of you
your right hand comes off another is for
defeating Ramon Salazar no thanks bro is
from this conversation I've been
expecting you my brethren
no thanks bro no thanks bro and finally
the big one Sadler himself beat him and
you'll see your small time in the
original re4 Leon delivered this
cringe-worthy line
Sadler your small time
old Leon never change a bit of law now
did you know that Leon was given his
name in homage to the movie Leon the
Professional this is also why the harder
difficulty mode is named professional
also in the movie Leon's Sidekick is
named Matilda and she became a weapon in
re4 and Leon's Close Quarters style has
been updated for the Remake too his new
style has him holding his gun at an
angle this is a very real stance yet
it's only become really popular in the
last 10 years with movies like John Wick
pushing this style although this stance
is definitely inspired by John Wick if
you've seen Leon's Evolution over the
years like in the movie Vendetta he's
been working on his Close Quarters
combat for years this I don't think is
an Easter egg but if I don't mention it
someone will get upset and come on it
does look totally badass another weapon
we can buy is the killer 7. this one is
actually from another Capcom game of the
same name killer 7 and that gun is also
Canon no pun intended in other games
like Dead Rising the killer 7 game
released a few months after re4 and just
like John Wick and Leon the Professional
the killer 7 are a group of Assassins
upon completing the game it's possible
to unlock cosmetic items and weapons
Leon gets this Dapper pinstripe suit and
Ashley gets a suit of ahma she even asks
for it during the game an amazing detail
can be found when Ashley wears the suit
and Leon is forced to catch her just for
a split second his back pain is evident
this armor must be heavy cause without
it he catches her without any issues at
all
my hero the best players in the world
will unlock the Chicago sweeper and the
Hand Cannon complete with unlimited ammo
which changed the standard ammo reload
into these balletic moves it's like
Michael Jackson meets Revolver Ocelot
the unlockable knife is the Primal blade
and surprisingly this is the knife Leon
had in the original game so why was it
taken out well it's due to a very
important update the knife Leon arrives
to Spain with is the very same one given
to him in Resident Evil 2 remake from
Marvin I Miss You Marvin a great Touch
of law between the two games and Leon
has also upgraded his pistol thanks to
another person he met in re2 this time
it's one of the Kendo boys his signature
can be spotted in photo mode iconic
Easter eggs you remember from childhood
are also back Leon can wander up and sit
on the Salazar Throne if he likes
nothing much happens but I remember
doing this in the original game as so
many games back then had Thrones yet no
game let us sit on one sit here long
enough and watch chickens poop out eggs
lovely
thrown eggs at people yet for some
reason rockets and grenades don't bother
the merchant but throw an egg at him and
Ashley and Louise are exactly the same
they don't like it but then it came to
light that the golden eggs can be used
as a weapon against Ramon by hitting him
in the face it's possible to knock him
to the ground ready for a knife
follow-up so eggs especially gold ones
are officially weapons in Resident Evil
4. other returning Easter eggs include
the weird and random ability to flip the
jet ski during the final mission of the
game you are racing to save your life
before the island explodes but Leon is
different he only sees the opportunity
to hit some gnarly air
Wolfie mcwolf face he can once again be
found stuck in a bear trap early in the
game and should you take the time to
free him he'll return in Epic fashion
later on in the first boss fight to help
you take that big lad down friends for
life and of course the Easter egg
everyone thinks of when they think of
Resident Evil 4. shooting the lake
results in this happening
I'm Adam you're awesome it's been a
pleasure I'll see you next time